Bonsoir à tous, Merci d'être avec nous.
C'est un grand honneur pour nous ce soir
de recevoir Marc
Augé dans nos mardis de l'Espace
des sciences.
Nous avons eu un petit rendez vous manqué
il y a un an ou deux, je crois.
Je ne sais plus exactement.
Donc on est encore doublement heureux
que vous soyez avec nous
ce soir,
d'autant plus que vous n'arrêtez pas.
Là, vous revenez d'Allemagne,
vous repartez à Douai demain.
Ensuite, vous allez en Suisse.
Vous êtes un vrai pigeon voyageur
et on a réussi à vous capter
comme ça à l'espace d'une soirée, un rêve.
Et nous en sommes très, très heureux.
Alors juste une petite information
que je voulais vous donner.
Avant de commencer, je voulais vous dire
que le nouveau numéro de Si on souhaite
vient juste de paraître,
C'est la revue de l'espace des sciences.
Vous en un exemplaire tout à l'heure,
avec un dossier
ce mois ci sur les médecine,
la médecine et les avancées.
Des avancées spectaculaires.
Voilà, c'est le titre de
Je ne vais pas vous en dire plus
parce que je n'ai
absolument pas eu le temps de de le voir.
Je l'ai eu seulement aujourd'hui.
On y parle aussi de biologie marine,
les forêts marines bretonnes
surveillées par les chercheurs.
Et comme d'habitude, vous avez plein
d'informations sur la recherche dans notre
dans notre région.
Je voulais aussi vous dire que je vais
vous abandonner pendant quelques semaines
pour m'en aller vers un coin
que vous connaissez bien, l'Afrique.
Et donc vous retrouverez dans les semaines
qui viennent mon amie
Sylvie Denis qui me qui me remplacera et
et nous avons de très beaux
rendez vous sur l'écologie du paysage
et la gestion de l'environnement
mardi prochain.
Et puis ensuite, on parlera du voyage.
On partira à la recherche des océans
extra terrestres.
Le 30 novembre
et puis après je serai de retour
pour finir la saison avant,
avant Noël avec vous.
Voilà donc Marc Augé avec nous ce soir.
Je n'aurais pas voulu rater
ce rendez vous pour rien au monde.
Vous êtes né à Poitiers un peu par hasard,
donc on ne va pas s'y attarder.
Je crois que vous y êtes resté un an
Et puis ensuite vous êtes parti à Paris.
On m'avait dit Est ce que je ne savais pas
trop ?
C'est que vous avez des attaches bretonnes
auxquelles vous êtes bien attaché
du côté de Trégunc ?
Oui, oui, bien sûr, parce que ma
grand mère était bretonne et parlait bien.
Et j'ai
J'ai passé toutes mes vacances
jusqu'à l'âge, jusqu'à un âge avancé
en Bretagne
et je n'ai que 25% de sont bretons,
mais c'était 100 fort, très fort
et j'y ai beaucoup de souvenirs.
La preuve, c'est que votre grand père
est catalan et que vous avez été colonisé.
Il a été colonisé par votre grand mère
bretonne.
On a les plus forts.
Alors vous avez un itinéraire
intéressant ?
Vous me disiez tout à l'heure qu'en fait
vous êtes arrivés à cette spécialité.
L'anthropologue J.J. L'ethnologie.
On parlera tout à l'heure des différences
entre tout ça.
Vous reviendrez sur sur ce sujet,
un peu comme ça,
presque par hasard, j'allais dire.
Mais ce n'est pas tout à fait ça
quand même.
C'est sans doute tout à fait ça,
parce qu'il y a sûrement
des raisons profondes pour essayer
d'élucider.
M'enfin, un peu quand même, parce que
j'avais fait des études de lettres et
je ne me sentais pas tout à fait
enthousiaste à l'idée
de faire une thèse de littérature sur
je ne sais quel auteur du XVIᵉ siècle
et pour lequel j'ai pour lesquels,
a priori, j'ai beaucoup de respect.
Mais ce n'était pas tout à fait
ce que j'avais envie de faire.
Mais je ne savais pas
exactement ce que j'avais
envie de faire
et c'est un ami qui m'a signalé que
il y avait des cursus
d'ethnologie
ou de sciences humaines en général,
parce que dans les années 60,
ce n'était pas, ce n'était pas universel,
très installé
et donc c'était un peu
une aventure intellectuelle.
Et il lui connaissait Georges Balandier
et il m'a présenté à lui
et nous avons fait affaire comme ça.
L'époque était particulière,
il fallait un peu de temps
et je ne suis pas parti tout de suite
en Afrique.
Et puis j'ai essayé d'apprendre un peu
ce que c'était que l'ethnologie,
mais j'ai un peu
enseigné dans le secondaire et quand j'ai
eu mon détachement pour un organisme
qui travaillait en Afrique,
alors vous avez travaillé pour leur Stomy
jusqu'aux années 70 70 jusqu'en 70.
Ensuite, vous avez été directeur d'études
à l'École
des hautes études en sciences sociales.
Et puis
vous avez été aussi le président de ce.
Oui, c'était en fait,
j'ai fait pas mal d'années.
Dix ans tout ça,
ça fait beaucoup de temps.
C'est depuis 70 et je suis toujours resté
à l'École des hautes études.
Mais la présider, c'était autre chose.
C'était un autre métier que j'ai exercé
pendant dix ans et de deux mandats.
Le quinquennat,
alors vous avez
effectué des missions en Afrique ?
D'abord, vous êtes resté de 65 à 70 ans
en Côte d'Ivoire ?
Oui, en Côte d'Ivoire
qui était mon premier terrain
et j'ai travaillé chez des Haladjian
qui étaient une société
petit groupe
et huit 9000 personnes qui
qui habitaient pas très loin d'Abidjan
à vrai dire.
Mais les chemins étaient un peu compliqué,
ce qui fait que c'était
entre lagune et la mer
et ça a été mon.
Mon premier terrain,
C'est le terrain que les ethnologue
n'oublient jamais
parce qu'on découvre tout à ce moment là.
Et on a un regard assez aigu,
en tout cas demandeur.
Et ensuite, je suis allé au Togo
tout en continuant
à aller en Côte d'Ivoire
qui est resté ma référence principale.
Et puis après,
ça a été l'Amérique latine ?
Oui, j'ai rencontré de l'Amérique latine
un peu tardivement,
dans les années 90
et enfin au début de 90.
Et c'était un grand enthousiasme.
Je trouvais ce continent fascinant, beau
et très intéressant.
Et je suis allé.
J'avais
des étudiants qui travaillaient là bas.
C'est comme ça que j'ai pris
contact de manière
un peu approfondie avec certains coins
au Venezuela ou au Brésil.
Et donc j'ai fait un peu de d'ethnologie
en amateur, en tout cas de seconde main.
Je suivais plutôt les travaux des autres
et je me laisse guider par des collègues.
Mais c'était passionnant
et j'ai noué pas mal
d'amitié, ce qui fait que j'y retourne
assez souvent.
Vous avez beaucoup écrit aussi.
Vous aimez voyager ?
Vous me le disiez tout à l'heure.
Les deux choses qui sont importantes
pour vous, c'est le voyage et l'écriture.
Je peux satisfaire complètement
maintenant les choses.
Je suis à la retraite, c'est formidable.
Vous êtes un homme heureux.
Alors vous avez écrit plusieurs livres,
dont certains, vous l'avez vu,
sont présentés là
haut grâce à la librairie Forum.
Donc vous irez en signer des exemplaires
pour ceux qui qui le désirent
tout à l'heure.
Alors si on parle de votre bibliographie,
il y a beaucoup de choses,
beaucoup de titres à citer,
certains livres qui sont réédités.
Vous me disiez tout à l'heure vous avez
beaucoup de rééditions en ce moment.
C'est vrai,
c'est
un hasard pour une anthropologie des.
Des modes contemporains,
des modes ou des mondes
des mondes contemporains.
Paru chez Stock
il y a déjà quelques années,
mais qui ressort en poche en 2010.
L'éloge de la bicyclette,
c'est chez Flammarion.
Moi, je l'ai vu annoncé, Je stock,
m'a envoyé toutes les informations.
Mais vous savez sûrement mieux que moi
l'éloge de la bicyclette.
Alors là,
on pourrait peut être en dire un mot
parce que justement,
ça me faisait penser au petit Marc Augé.
Parce que vous le dites d'ailleurs,
au début de ce livre,
on ne peut pas parler de la bicyclette
sans sans parler de soi.
Et finalement,
c'est pas mal sur les routes de Bretagne
que vous avez roulé à bicyclette ?
Bien sûr, je sais, je sais, la bicyclette
à quatorze quinze ans,
sur les routes de Bretagne
et en plus je suivais le Tour de France.
Ah oui, il n'y avait pas la télévision,
mais on voyait le bistrot
du coin
afficher les trois premiers de l'étape
et les lignes et les trois premiers
du classement général chaque soir.
Et c'est là que j'ai appris aussi
à ne pas être trop patriotes.
Parce que moi, j'étais
un fanatique de Fausto Coppi.
Oui, alors voilà.
Louison Bobet, vous en parlez ?
Ah oui, oui, j'aimais bien Bobet,
mais il est venu juste un petit peu après.
Alors c'est bien
parce qu'il y a plusieurs chapitres,
bien sûr, à ce livre la lumière vécue.
Vous parlez de la crise,
vous parlez bien sûr du dopage, et cetera
Vous parlez de l'utopie, alors ?
Moi j'adore ce ces spationautes,
tous astronautes
qui fait du vélo sur Mars.
Nous avait imaginé ça.
Peut être qu'on verra ça un jour.
Malheureusement, il faut revenir
sur terre, mais c'est un livre.
C'est un petit livre
très, très sympathique qui est paru
aux éditions Paillou.
Et puis alors, où est passé l'avenir ?
Un joli titre aussi, qui est réédité
en Point Seuil en début d'année, je crois.
Et puis
alors,
vous aimez bien les moyens de locomotion ?
Il y a aussi un ethnologue dans le métro.
Un livre qui a dû paraître vers 1989.
Et puis, 20 ans après, vous êtes,
vous avez remis le ?
Oui, parce que le métro, c'est ça exerce
un effet grossissant.
On voit dans le métro
qu'est ce qui est à la surface,
mais on ne le voit plus condensée
dans le métro.
Dans les changements de population.
Dans les.
Dans l'évolution des comportements,
des habitudes, et cetera
Alors c'est intéressant de faire un 20 ans
après.
Ah oui, même si c'est un peu triste
de renaître à écrire à 20 ans seulement.
Maintenant, pourquoi une ?
Et puis il y a la communauté illusoire
qui est parue, qui va paraître
un peu perdue dans les dates,
la communauté illusoire.
C'est
un tout petit livre qui était là haut.
Je suis idiote, je l'ai bien.
Non, non, c'est encore un autre.
Mais voilà,
il y en a tellement que je m'y perds.
Enfin, vous allez, vous allez
allez voir sur la table du libraire.
Vous pouvez aussi les emprunter
au troisième étage de la bibliothèque
des Champs Libres, à l'étage,
consacré aux sciences,
aux sciences et aux techniques.
Vous pouvez l'emprunter
d'emprunter là bas.
Donc moi, j'ai ici où est passé l'avenir ?
Le métier d'anthropologue
pour une anthropologie de la mobilité,
puis, bien sûr, l'éloge de la bicyclette.
Voilà.
Ce soir, on va parler de ce métier
d'anthropologue de l'anthropologie
aujourd'hui.
Et puis, comme vous le disiez,
vous avez peut être commencé
tout de suite par vous expliquer
un petit peu cette différence.
J'ai l'impression
que tout le monde se pose la question
et qu'on n'a pas vraiment de réponse
satisfaisante entre tout.
C'est ces spécialités qui se terminent par
oui, elles se recouvrent un peu les unes
les autres,
mais je crois que c'est important
quand même d'essayer de définir
la spécificité de chacune d'entre elles.
Un ethnologue, c'est quelqu'un
qui travaille sur un petit groupe
puisqu'il travaille seul.
Je crois que l'exercice ethnologique
est un exercice
solitaire, en tout cas pas solitaire,
parce qu'on est avec plein de monde, mais
qui se fait professionnellement, seul
et au fond, l'idéal de l'ethnologue, c'est
de décrire de façon exhaustive
un groupe ou une société
et de la décrire exhaustivement.
L'ethnographe, c'est celui qui
qui en décrit certains aspects.
L'ethnologue aspire à plus de totalités.
Quant à l'anthropologie,
je dirai qu'elle est plus comparative.
Elle est comparative en deux sens.
On peut faire une
anthropologie de la parenté,
comparer les systèmes de parenté entre eux
ou une anthropologie du pouvoir,
les formes de pouvoir entre elles et.
Et donc l'anthropologie peut déboucher
sur une réflexion plus générale
qui repose sur des terrains,
tandis que ethnologie, c'est
le moment qui précède en quelque sorte.
C'est l'étude aussi attentive que possible
et aussi exhaustive que possible
d'un groupe donné.
Vous allez nous expliquer ça
dans le détail ?
Alors, juste avant que vous rejoignez
votre votre pupitre, je voudrais préciser
que cette conférence est enregistrée
par le créa de l'université Rennes deux.
Merci à eux.
Ils sont là,
derrière les caméras et en régie.
Donc dans quelques semaines,
nous pourrons réécouter cette
cette conférence
sur le site de l'Espace des sciences.
Merci aussi
à tous ceux qui se trouvent en régie.
Et puis pour terminer, je voudrais juste
citer une petite phrase de vous J'espère
qu'elle est vraiment de vous
parce que quelquefois nous trompe.
Que je trouve assez jolie
à propos justement.
Des différences comme les spécialités
entre l'historien et le et l'ethnologue.
La différence, c'est
que l'historien connaît la suite,
non ?
Voilà, je vous laisse.
Et puis on se retrouve tout à l'heure
pour vos questions.
Très bonne soirée à tous.
Et bien,
je vais commencer en effet
par rappeler ce que c'est
qu'un ethnologue,
parce que c'est une question difficile
qu'on m'a posé
l'anthropologie aujourd'hui.
Il y a tellement de choses à dire,
mais je vais essayer
d'être relativement bref
en essayant d'être relativement clair.
L'ethnologue Traditionnellement,
c'est vrai que c'est
une fonction qu'on associe au voyage et
parce que le ethnologue est celui qui part
dans un continent plus ou moins lointain
et qui va s'exercer à regarder les autres.
On pensait même
que cette vertu du regard éloigné
peut s'exercer ensuite
sur sa propre société.
À la faveur de cette expérience, je crois
que les choses ont changé aujourd'hui.
L'ethnologie
ne s'exerce pas nécessairement
dans des territoires lointains.
Ce qui compte, c'est le type de regard
que l'on porte sur les choses.
Je crois que tout anthropologie
a une vertu critique
en ce sens qu'elle essaie
d'analyser, de mettre au jour ce qui,
dans l'ordinaire
des jours, apparaît comme naturel.
Et l'ethnologue est celui qui s'exerce
d'abord sur d'autres sociétés.
Et c'est de montrer
que ce naturel est relatif,
qu'il est toujours d'ordre culturel.
D'une certaine manière,
et de ce point de vue, c'est un exercice
qui a toujours un côté un peu subversif
dans la mesure où, précisément,
ce qui apparaît évident
aux yeux de tout le monde
peut l'être moins lorsqu'on
regarde d'un peu loin.
En fait, l'ethnologue a
un objet intellectuel particulier
qui est la relation,
la relation entre l'un et l'autre, ou l'un
et les autres, ou les uns et les autres.
Et cette relation,
il essaie de la saisir sur sous
ses différents aspects.
On parle des relations de parenté,
on parle des relations de pouvoir,
on parle des relations
de camaraderie, de génération.
Tout ça, c'est ça l'objet de l'ethnologie.
Une ethnologie
qui peut donner lieu à une anthropologie
quand on essaie
d'élargir le champ de vision
et qu'à partir
des expériences singulières,
on introduit la comparaison
pour faire une anthropologie
de la parenté, des systèmes matrimoniaux,
des systèmes de filiation, et cetera
Mais c'est vrai aussi dans le domaine
d'autres domaines, dans le domaine de
l'économie ou dans le domaine du pouvoir,
on parle d'anthropologie économique
ou d'anthropologie politique.
Sur la base de comparaison possible
entre différents exemples.
L'ethnologue travail C'est
la première partie, au fond de ce qu'il
fait, de ce que fait
ou de ce que peut faire l'anthropologue.
C'est le travail sur une société donnée,
sur un groupe donné
pour essayer de l'approfondir.
Mais ce qui l'étudie prioritairement
dans cet effort là, au terme de cet
effort là, c'est la relation.
D'une certaine
manière, c'est ce qui ferait un peu
la frontière
entre les différentes disciplines.
Je ne ne crois pas qu'il y ait
des frontières absolues entre
les disciplines de sciences humaines,
mais il y a des zones de recouvrement
et des zones frontières en quelque sorte.
Et l'ethnologie s'intéresse
donc à la relation, je le disais,
c'est à dire dans un autre langage.
On dira au symbolique
la manière dont se pense et se crée
la relation entre les uns et les autres.
Et alors que la psychologie
part de l'individu
et que la sociologie traite davantage
des grands groupes en tant que telle.
Alors, encore une fois avec des nuances,
parce qu'il
n'y a pas de coupure absolue
entre ces différents efforts.
Mais l'accent est mis sur la relation
dans ce qui concerne,
pour ce qui concerne l'ethnologie,
mais la relation,
elle, doit s'observer dans son contexte
et c'est
donc ça le double objet de l'ethnologie
la relation dans son contexte,
dans son contexte.
Parce que ce n'est pas exactement
la même chose d'étudier
un village, un petit campement isolé
au fond de la forêt amazonienne
ou un village africain qui fait partie
d'un ensemble politique d'un royaume
ou sur
qui est sur une grande voie commerciale
avec un relais de commerce
entre le Sahel et la mer.
Autrement dit,
il y a des situations spatiales,
mais aussi historiques différentes,
dont il faut tenir compte pour appréhender
l'étude locale elle même.
Et le problème aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'il y a toujours des relations.
J'y reviendrai, mais que le contexte
a changé partout aujourd'hui.
De fil en aiguille, même si on se trouve
au fin fond de l'Amazonie,
le contexte, en définitive,
est toujours planétaire.
C'est à dire qu'il y a toujours,
par une série de médiation et de relais,
une référence
à la situation globale de la planète.
Et c'est ce qui donne à la recherche
anthropologique un nouvel horizon.
Progressivement,
nous sommes passés de l'âge
de la colonisation à l'âge
de la globalisation
et c'est
quelque chose qui se sent de manière
très concrète dans l'expérience
que l'on peut avoir
de tel ou tel endroit
et je partirai,
si vous voulez, de la notion de lieu.
Lorsque je suis arrivé en Afrique
dans les 65 en 1965,
j'étais dans un village
organisé
en moitié avec des quartiers bien affirmés
et je me trouvais en somme à l'aise
par rapport à ce que j'avais pu
lire dans les manuels
ou dans les autres ouvrages d'ethnologie.
Il y avait un lieu dont je pressentais
qu'on pouvait déchiffrer
en le parcourant du regard
les grands traits
de l'organisation sociale.
C'est ce que j'ai appelé le lieu
anthropologique, le lieu anthropologique.
C'est le lieu sur lequel l'anthropologue
peut lire
quelque chose de la structure sociale.
Alors il peut lire quelque chose
de la structure sociale parce que,
notamment,
il y a beaucoup de sociétés
dans lesquelles on ne peut pas vivre
n'importe où.
C'est à dire qu'il
y a des systèmes prescriptif qui disent
si l'on vit chez son père
ou si l'on vit chez son oncle maternel
et si la femme reste chez elle
ou si elle vient rejoindre son mari,
à quel moment
on a fabriqué des mots savants
pour dire sa patrie locale,
matrice locale locale.
Mais ce sont des mots compliqués
pour des choses relativement simples.
Les règles de résidence
sont, dans beaucoup de sociétés
que l'ethnologie étudiée ou étudie.
Traditionnellement,
les règles de résidence sont
prescriptive.
Respecter.
Autrement dit, quand on fait l'inventaire,
le recensement d'un petit village ou d'un
campement est bien.
Comme ces règles
sont en général appliquées,
on a une idée de la situation sociale
parce que je prends
un bref exemple si vous voulez,
du groupe dans lequel je me trouvais
dans les années 60,
c'était une société matrilinéaire,
une société matrilinéaire.
C'est une société où l'appartenance
au groupe passe par les femmes,
c'est à dire qu'on appartient au lignage
de sa mère, pas à celui de son père.
Alors
ça n'empêche que ce sont des sociétés
où les hommes ont le pouvoir,
la réalité du pouvoir.
Mais celle là, c'est l'oncle maternel
qui a l'autorité sur son neveu utérin
plus que sur ses fils à lui qui, eux,
voient l'autorité
détenue par leurs propres
oncles maternels.
Société matrilinéaire
mais patrie locale, c'est
à dire que les enfants vivent chez leur
père.
Autrement dit, c'est ce qu'on
appelle en ethnologie une société
dite harmonique
où les règles de la filiation
et les règles de
la résidence ne coïncident pas.
Bon, je ne vais pas me lancer
dans tout cela.
C'est très complexe.
Ça peut devenir relativement complexe,
mais cela signifie qu'en
décrit
en décrivant l'installation physique,
la répartition dans l'espace
et les maisons des personnes,
on a une idée des liens sociaux
qui s'y établissent.
Alors, dans la définition
du lieu, il y a d'autres choses
que les règles de résidence.
Il y a évidemment
les objets de culte,
le culte partagé, les dieux, les génies.
Il est de quelques noms qu'on les appelle,
qui sont les uns individuels,
les autres collectifs, et cetera
Mais c'est quelque chose
que nous nous connaissons
le juge
dans la recherche du temps
perdu, dans les premiers volumes,
le temps de l'attente du narrateur
est à son village
et elle regarde
par la fenêtre et elle observe tout.
Et elle est elle explique bien que
si on fait par la bouche du narrateur,
c'est s'il y a un chien
qu'on ne connaît pas.
On est satisfait
que lorsqu'on sait que c'est
le chien de telle personne qui est venu
rendre visite à tel autre, n'est ce pas ?
Nous avons tous une idée de ce que c'est
qu'un lieu où les contraintes spatiales
se combinent avec celle de la famille
et de la résidence.
Il n'y a pas d'étrangers
dans un lieu comme cela, ou tout au moins,
il est connoté
tout de suite comme étranger.
Alors ces sociétés
et ces sociétés
de la première,
étudiée par la première ethnologie,
sont des sociétés
où la filiation,
la résidence, l'alliance matrimoniale
sont cohérentes, joue ensemble et
établissent
un système de sens, de sens social.
Il y a des contraintes,
des systèmes d'obligations.
C'est vrai qu'il y a des
il y a des sociétés qui ont
et qui ont des interdits matrimoniaux,
mais il y en a aussi
qui ont des prescriptions matrimoniales.
Il y a des sociétés
dans lesquelles on est obligé
d'épouser la cousine croisée
ou quelque chose comme ça,
par exemple,
Lévi-Strauss a étudié
en Amérique latine, au Brésil
les différents groupes,
notamment
les Bororos ou les systèmes à moitié
des villages, entraîne
qu'on est toujours obligé de se marier.
Dans l'autre moitié.
Il y a deux moitiés dans chaque village
et on est obligé
d'inter changer entre les deux moitiés
pour l'alliance matrimoniale,
tout cela se combinant avec trois classes
sociales d'une manière assez complexe.
Bref, le lieu en ce sens, c'est un espace
sur lequel
on peut lire toutes les subtilités
et toutes les complexités
de l'organisation sociale
et s'est associé généralement
à une vision immanente des choses
où il n'y a pas une coupure radicale
entre les morts et les vivants
entre l'un et l'autre.
Il y a des conceptions de la personne
qui sont subtiles et des conceptions
de l'hérédité des conceptions de la,
de tout ce qui s'hérite dans la personne.
Nous savons aussi quelque chose de cela.
Je pense à ces villages
organisés, ces villages.
On trouve la structure ancienne
où notamment.
Le cimetière est autour de l'église, l
église au centre du village,
le cimetière autour de l'église
et puis les rues qui convergent
vers l'est, vers l'église.
C'était c'est bien
un système comme cela de lieu
ou qui implique
une espèce de communication, de communion
entre morts et vivants
rassemblés autour de l'Église.
Il y a des choses comme ça qui
ne nous
surprennent pas vraiment,
même si elles sont organisées
d'une manière spécifique
dans telle ou telle culture.
Alors,
le lieu étant défini comme cela,
nous pouvons faire une remarque simple
qui est que dans le monde actuel
contemporain se développe
un certain nombre d'espaces
qui sont des non-lieux sont des non-lieux.
Pourquoi ? Parce que
on ne peut pas,
par leur simple description,
entrer dans une évocation
précise de l'organisation sociale.
Ce sont tous les espaces de circulation,
de consommation
et même de communication qui, aujourd'hui,
se développent à un rythme accéléré
circulation un aéroport
et communication un supermarché.
Vous ne pouvez pas décrire
immédiatement
un aéroport ou un supermarché
et donner l'organisation sociale.
C'est fréquenté essentiellement
par des individus qui se croisent,
qui coexistent, mais qui n'en n'ont pas
a priori entre eux de lien,
de lien qui soit analysable comme cela.
On ne peut pas lire l'organisation
du social à travers ces espaces
et c'est pour cela que je les avais appelé
d'abord non-lieux.
Alors bien entendu,
cette notion de non-lieu est relative
parce que ce qui est un lieu pour les uns
peut être un non-lieu pour les autres
et vice versa.
J'avais remarqué, notamment en Bretagne.
Dans certains endroits,
il y avait des supermarchés
qui se situaient à égale
distance de plusieurs villages
et dont c'était d'une
certaine manière le comble du non-lieu,
puisque c'est un espace où on se rend
pour faire des courses.
Mais c'était devenu un lieu de rendez vous
pour un certain nombre de jeunes gens
qui y trouvaient d'une part une occasion
de se rencontrer, d'autre part,
des choses qui leur
plaisir, des instruments,
des technologies modernes, et cetera
Donc voilà,
et ils en avaient fait un lieu.
De même, ce n'est pas la même chose
de passer dans un aéroport
pour y prendre un avion
ou d'y travailler tous les jours.
Quand il y a des collègues à
l'aéroport peut être parfaitement un lieu
pour certains, alors que pour d'autres,
ce serait un non lieu.
La difficulté de la notion de
non lieu, c'est qu'il
y a sa définition théorique,
c'est à dire un espace
à travers l'analyse
duquel on ne peut pas faire sortir
la société parce qu'elle est en dehors
ou à côté, ou qu'elle est plus complexe
que les non-lieux et d'un autre côté,
il y a une définition empirique
les espaces de communication,
de circulation et de consommation
qui se développent à vitesse accélérée.
Et voilà
le problème,
c'est que les espaces de communication
eux mêmes
posent un problème particulier
les espaces de communication.
Ils sont de deux sortes.
Il y a la télévision et il y a Internet,
les ordinateurs, et cetera
La télévision,
elle, fait partie du contexte
et non pas de la relation, dira t on.
La télévision, c'est ce qui nous montre
le monde de tous les jours,
le monde dans lequel nous vivons,
qui le montre sous un angle particulier,
mais qui le montre et nous donne donc
le sentiment de faire partie du monde.
Simplement, ça n'est pas sans ambiguïté
parce que nous y voyons tous les jours
des figures
qui nous deviennent familières,
que ce soit les figures des présentateurs,
des animateurs, et cetera
qui deviennent des fréquentations parfois
quotidiennes, régulières en tout cas,
ou bien même les grands de ce monde
qui nous donnent le sentiment
d'être des figures familières.
Tous les jours,
je peux voir Obama, Sarkozy, et cetera.
Donc il y a cette impression que nous
les connaissons
est évidemment une illusion
parce que nous croyons les connaître,
parce que nous les reconnaissons.
Il y a un effet de reconnaissance
qui s'attache à l'écran de télévision,
qui nous donne
un sentiment d illusoire familiarité.
Les producteurs de télévision savent bien
qu'on peut reprocher à la télévision
d'entretenir des relations passives.
Et les spectacles nous sont imposés.
Les chaînes essaient de retenir
l'attention, de faire un public captif
et à cette occasion, ils se présentent
comme des métaphores de lieux.
Ils ont leur idée.
Chaque chaîne de télévision
est une île dans l'océan médiatique
et on essaie de nous retenir
dans cette île
en nous montrant les programmes,
même avec les
rendez vous réguliers
qu'on essaie de nous donner un peu.
De la même façon que Jacques Le Goff
décrivait le rôle des cloches des églises
au Moyen Âge pour ponctuer la journée
en fonction de de la religion.
Eh bien, la télévision a ses rendez
vous réguliers.
Le 20 h, c'est la, c'est la grand messe.
D'ailleurs,
la métaphore est utilisée parfois, mais ça
l'est presque au sens littéral, en ce sens
que ça nous donne un rendez vous.
Il y a donc tout un effort de ce
ces écrans de télévision
pour se comporter comme s'ils étaient
un véritable lieu de rendez vous.
Tout cela est évidemment assez construit.
Et pour lutter contre la
contre la passivité du téléspectateur,
on essaie d'en faire un complice.
Dans télévision,
le mot télé qui veut dire au loin
est en fait abusif parce que
nous voyons de très près les choses.
Au contraire.
Je pense d'ailleurs que c'est peut être
une raison
pour laquelle les imitateurs ont tellement
de succès aujourd'hui,
parce que qui imitent les imitateurs,
les imitateurs imitent les grands
de ce monde, les personnalités politiques
ou les artistes ou les auteurs
ou les présentateurs eux mêmes.
C'est une complicité en circuit fermé et
la tentative
d'animation de la télévision
est le succès. Quand les imitateurs
me semblent
faire partie de ce monde de connivence
qu'on essaie d'établir
avec le spectateur
pour lui faire croire qu'il est chez lui
connaissance, reconnaissance,
la reconnaissance
se substitue à la connaissance
et c'est un aspect important d'une
relation qui est une relation passive.
Mais on me dira qu'avec Internet,
j'en reste toujours à ce troisième
volet des non-lieux, circulations,
consommation, communication.
Deuxième aspect de la communication
qui est évidemment plus actif
sur tous les instruments comme Internet
et qui peuvent donner le sentiment à tout
un chacun,
pourvu
qu'il ait la capacité de le faire quand
il agit, qu'il est et qu'il est actif
d'ailleurs.
Maintenant, on assiste à une tentative
des chaînes de télévision pour
permettre de brancher les ordinateurs
sur les écrans de télévision, de sorte
qu'on ait une télévision interactive.
Donner encore
le sentiment de participation
alors,
Internet, bien sûr, et c'est
un instrument prodigieux,
mais ça n'est pas
un instrument pédagogique.
Je veux dire qu'il
y a toute la connaissance du monde
a priori dans Internet, mais
c'est toute la connaissance du monde.
Mais elle n'apprend quelque chose
qu'à ceux qui savent déjà.
On ne peut pas apprendre sur Internet,
à moins d'être guidé par quelqu'un,
et cetera
Ça supposerait tout un système
dans toute une organisation.
Internet, c'est donc
un instrument de renseignement,
de connaissance et qui,
mais qui a des prétentions plus grandes
dans l'usage qu'en font certains.
Prétention à créer une société qui double
la société réelle, une société virtuelle
qui existe comme telle.
On sait très bien qu'il y a des tentatives
pour créer des relations entre des gens
très éloignés les uns des autres.
C'est assez fascinant d'ailleurs
pour faire des
communiqués, comme on dit anglais,
soit sur des grands jeux, soit simplement
pour le plaisir de se connaître.
Alors ça peut être interprété
comme une sorte d'agenda
un peu qui permettrait à
des gens de faire connaissance
et de se retrouver éventuellement.
Mais il y a certainement chez d'autres
un Un but plus ample,
c'est de se dire qu'il
y a une véritable société d'échange
qui peut exister
sur le mode virtuel entre des personnes
qui ne se connaissent pas.
Autrement dit, une société un peu rêvée
et qui,
de ce point de vue,
on ne peut pas s'empêcher de penser.
Certains textes de Freud,
qui distinguent l'enfance de l'adolescence
en ce sens que l'enfant qui joue,
joue, puis, quand il s'arrête de jouer,
il est dans le réel, il sait qu'il a joué,
et alors on parle.
Il parle de la Freud, de la période
adolescente comme celle de la rêverie,
de la fantaisie, du fantasme
où l'adolescent
risque de se prendre à ses rêves
et a mélangé un peu
ses propres fantasmes avec la réalité.
Ce qui comporte heureusement pas toujours,
mais un risque de névrose.
Je me demande si, de ce point de vue,
d'un point de vue plus collectif,
il n'y a pas une dimension névrotique
dans le rapport à l'imaginaire d'Internet
tel qu'il peut se constituer de façon
un peu déviée.
On a évoqué d'ailleurs tout cela
à propos du Japon notamment,
où les adolescents vivaient enfermés
dans leur chambre,
constamment dans des relations virtuelles
avec un environnement
qui les accaparait entièrement.
Bref, lieu non lieu,
opposition
qui doit se comprendre comme relative
mais qui change
les conditions de l'observation
dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui
il est de plus en plus difficile
d abstraire
contexte particulier du contexte général
et le contexte particulier
d'un petit village,
ou qu'il se trouve qu'il est,
du fait des relais médiatiques
plus ou moins agissants,
un contexte plus large que cela.
Quant à la relation, eh bien,
elle peut être touchée
par l'illusion de relation que peut donner
l'instrument technologique.
Un autre aspect du monde actuel,
c'est évidemment l'urbanisation.
Urbanisation, c'est un mot
qui est à peu près
l'équivalent de celui de globalisation.
Aujourd'hui,
la globalisation, c'est la,
c'est l'uniformisation de la terre
sous l'aspect technologique et économique.
C'est le fait que du marché libéral
et des technologies qui nous renvoient
à la planète dans son ensemble
et non plus à tel espace particulier.
Mais l'urbanisation,
elle, est un peu du même ordre
et elle s'appuie sur ces technologies.
L'urbanisation
de la planète
correspond à un phénomène de croissance
qui a lui même deux aspects
la croissance des mégapoles.
On sait que les grandes métropoles
ne cesse de s'accroître.
On parle du Grand Paris aujourd'hui,
mais toutes les grandes métropoles
ne cesse de s'accroître,
notamment du fait de l'exode rural,
et cetera.
Autrement dit,
le premier phénomène d'urbanisation.
Il y a un pour centage énorme de gens
qui vivent en ville sur la terre,
c'est l'extension des mégapoles.
Mais il y a un autre aspect des choses
que Hervé
Le Bras, le démographe avait bien souligné
qui est cette espèce de
de progression
des filaments urbains,
comme il les appelle,
qui existe entre les villes elles mêmes.
Il y a aussi
on peut passer d'une ville à l'autre
sans avoir le sentiment
de passer par la campagne.
En quelque sorte.
Il y a des filaments le long des côtes,
le long des voies de communication,
le long des des fleuves.
Donc, c'est le double aspect
de cette croissance urbaine
croissance des grands centres urbains
et urbanisation rampante et qui
et qui fait que,
notamment en Europe
où l'espace est plus réduit qu'ailleurs,
les villes se touchent, sont soudées
en elles par une sorte d'arthrose
progressive.
Les géographes ont un terme pour désigner
l'arc de lumière
qu'on voit sur les photos satellitaires
qui va de Manchester à la plaine du Pô.
La nuit, ça fait avec les lumières,
ça dessine comme un arc bleu
et ils appellent ça la banane bleue.
La banane bleue, c'est le champ.
C'est
cet arc bleu lumineux
qu'on voit
sur les photos de satellites qui
brise la nuit sur l'Europe.
Alors, à cette croissance urbaine
correspond un monde en réseau
les réseaux
qui correspondent eux
mêmes aux technologies dont j'ai signalé
le développement et qui se recoupent
sur des pôles puissants.
Les grandes,
les grandes mégapoles aujourd'hui
sont des lieux où se retrouvent toutes
les dimensions humanitaires,
qu'elles soient dans les pays
développés ou dans les pays
en développement.
Il y a des concentrations considérables
où se retrouvent un nombre considérable
d'hommes, d'individus,
mais aussi d'universités,
de centres de recherche,
de deux centres économiques
et de lieux de décision.
Autrement dit, la globalisation, c'est
plutôt une série de pôles
dont les plus nombreux seront,
mais pas exclusivement en Amérique
et à moindre titre en Europe
ou au Japon ou en Chine.
Donc ce n'est pas exclusif.
Donc des pôles et des réseaux
de toutes sortes, y compris
les circulations qui les unissent,
ce qui fait que nous avons.
Nous assistons progressivement à
une organisation en réseau de type filet.
Et n'est ce pas comme un filet
qui enserre le monde et
qui se retrouve aussi bien
dans les
leurs, dans le dispositif technologique
des moyens de communication ?
Paul Virilio avait employé
pour désigner cette urbanisation
le terme de méta cité virtuelle.
La cité virtuelle,
c'est justement l'ensemble
de ces réseaux de communication
qui se regroupent sur des pôles
qui concentrent eux
mêmes les différents réseaux.
On peut le dire autrement,
on peut le dire autrement
et opposer par exemple,
les réalités du monde ville,
c'est à dire ce monde qui progressivement
devient comme une ville
et celle de la ville monde,
c'est à dire
la mégapole qui grandit énormément.
Quand nous perdons des images du monde
ville, qu'est ce que nous voyons ?
Et bien nous voyons tout
ce qui nous suggère que le monde
se uniformise
et que c'est un ensemble transparent
où la mobilité est incessante.
Les avions décollent.
Nous avons toutes sortes d'images de
ce genre où les voiliers
font le tour du monde
sous l'oeil des caméras.
Ou il y a cette image
d'un monde translucide.
Et un peu le même, toujours
parce que les chaînes de télévision
sont les mêmes, et cetera mais
où tout circule,
où tout est transparent
et tout est fluide,
où il n'y a pas de frontières, c'est
un monde sans frontières, nous dit on.
Et puis, à ces réalités là s'oppose
celle de la ville monde, c'est à dire
les grandes cités qui sont si grandes
qu'on y retrouve
toutes les dimensions mondiales,
mais toutes les dimensions mondiales.
Ça veut dire aussi toutes les différences,
toutes les ethnies
et toutes les religions,
toutes les cultures, toutes les situations
sociales, toutes les conditions sociales
et aussi les barrières.
C'est à propos des grandes villes
des grandes cités que nous
parlons de ghettos,
que nous parlons, de quartiers interdits.
Aux États-Unis, il y a des villes privées,
il y a des quartiers
dans toutes les villes du monde,
mais de manière plus ou moins marquée,
qui sont interdits à certains
et les barrières,
les quartiers dits difficiles,
tout ça, ça apparaît dans la grande,
dans la grande cité qui est le monde ville
et qui est en contraste
avec la définition de
la ville monde.
Je vais dire qui est en contraste
avec l'apparente fluidité,
homogénéité, libre circulation
du monde, ville.
Donc je crois que cette opposition
entre ville, monde et monde ville
est assez opérante.
Je voudrais prendre un autre exemple
pour préciser un peu ce
je veux dire celui de l'architecture.
Les plus grands,
les grands architectes aujourd'hui,
sont davantage connus du public
que les grands artistes.
Peut être même que les grands écrivains.
Les noms des grands architectes
comme Jerry Foster nouvelles
sont connus dans grand public et
ils jouent un rôle assez extraordinaire
parce que dans toutes les grandes villes,
dans toutes ces mégapoles que j'évoquais
à l'instant, ces architectes construisent,
construisent un ou deux bâtiments,
et cetera et des villes
qui sont d'importance moyenne
aspirent à avoir un bâtiment
de l'un de ces architectes
pour signifier qu'elle
appartient au réseau, qu'il s'agit
d'être dans le réseau global pour exister.
Et l'architecture
peut être un symbole de tout cela.
Bilbao Le musée de Bilbao
est connu, c'est galeries et
on trouve aussi bien à Berlin
mais qu'à Paris
le. Le fait
que ces signatures individuelles
se retrouvent aux quatre coins du monde,
à Shanghaï comme à New York ou à Chicago,
est intéressant parce qu'il montre qu'il
y a une couleur globale
qui se substitue à ce qu'on appelait jadis
la couleur locale,
La couleur locale, bien entendu,
les architectes y prétendent
parce que dans les projets architecturaux,
on évoque le contexte,
les nécessités du contexte immédiat.
Il n'empêche que ces architectures
évoquent beaucoup les unes les autres
et que, tout en respectant
peut être certains critères locaux,
leur finalité ultime, c'est de figurer
dans le grand réseau global.
Et elles figurent dans le grand réseau
global et, du coup, attire
un public de touristes
qui est un public planétaire.
Bilbao est une ville où l'on vient,
non pas pour voir ce qu'il
y a dans le musée,
mais pour voir le musée lui même,
parce qu'il est l'œuvre
que l'on vient voir.
C'est donc une espèce de référence
imposée.
Le grand architecte
Rem Koolhaas avait dit à propos du
contexte fait que ce contexte,
c'était une expression un peu vigoureuse,
mais qui signifiait bien
que le contexte aujourd'hui
est planétaire et que ça n'a
pas de sens de prétendre autre chose.
Ce qui fait que
nous sommes ici dans un
immeuble qui a une signature célèbre.
Eh bien, ça prouve
que Rennes fait partie du réseau et.
En tout cas,
c'est c'est assez significatif.
Je crois que l'ensemble
de la grande d'architecture de marché
contribue à l'existence de ce monde ville
qui devient le vrai
contexte de la ville monde.
Alors on parle d'un monde sans frontières.
Alors c'est une double erreur, bien sûr,
puisqu'il y a des frontières et que
on voit bien que les réalités
de la vie de la ville
monde démentent l'idéal de transparence
et de fluidité
qui s'attache aux images du monde ville.
Mais d'un autre côté,
la deuxième erreur, c'est que
la frontière de la frontière n'est
pas une barrière.
Je crois au contraire qu'il faut revenir
sur l'idée de frontières, la frontière.
Il n'y a pas une barrière, c'est un seuil.
Lorsqu'on parle de la frontière
des langues, par exemple,
une langue, ça peut s'apprendre
et donc il y a un effort
pour aller vers l'autre qui consiste
par exemple à faire l'apprentissage
de sa langue
ou de son langage éventuellement.
Autrement dit, le
ce que nous devons, me semble t
il, apprendre à reconnaître,
c'est les frontières.
Il faut les reconnaître.
Il faut les jusque dans leur
finalité ultime
qui est de protéger l'individu
et l'individu
souverain.
C'est l'individu
dont on respecte les frontières,
dont on respecte la vie privée,
dont on respecte les sentiments.
Et c'est quelque chose
sans doute de plus important que tout.
Je crois
donc que cette notion de frontière
qui marque un seuil et les seuils.
L'ethnologie l'a assez montré.
Ça se passe
avec des procédures de ritualisation.
Respecter les choses pour franchir
les frontières, ça se franchit Donc
que nous soyons,
que nous allions vers un monde
sans barrières, ce serait formidable,
mais ça n'est pas le cas.
En revanche, un monde sans frontières,
je ne pense pas que ce soit souhaitable.
Je voudrais résumer autrement
la situation vers laquelle nous allons
aujourd'hui.
Je dirais qu'il s'agit ici, je l'ai dit,
permettez l'expression
d'un triple décentrement,
un sens, un décentrement de la ville.
D'abord,
nous continuons,
nous parlons d'urbanisation du monde.
Mais est ce que la ville n'a pas changé ?
Est ce que c'est
de la même ville que nous parlons ?
Evidemment non.
Nous sommes dans la ville extra muros.
La ville est aujourd'hui
la grande ville
qui veut exister dans le monde
ou la ville moyenne
qui veut accéder à cette dignité.
Elle se décentre
parce qu'elle vaut d'abord
par ses rapports avec l'extérieur.
Elle doit exporter des biens,
des produits, des hommes,
des images, des messages et en recevoir.
Elle est sa priorité, c'est le contact
avec l'extérieur et ça se traduit
dans l'espace par l'importance
de l'aéroport, par exemple
les grands aéroports aujourd'hui.
D'ailleurs.
Quelquefois, on emploie
le nom de l'aéroport pour désigner
la destination, la ville pour les grosses
concentrations urbaines.
Et c'est
cette ville qui éclate
et dont il faut le concevoir aussi,
parallèlement à la muséification
des centres historiques.
Il y a de moins en moins de monde,
C'est de moins en moins habiter
les centres historiques des villes.
Ils sont de moins en moins habités.
Ils sont très chers à habiter
parce qu'ils sont plutôt mis en scène
pour accueillir les touristes,
y compris du monde entier,
qui vont les visiter comme des
comme un décor.
Et alors même que les centres économiques,
les centres de vie, et cetera sont
assez largement aux périphéries.
On pourrait faire toute une sociologie
du RER à Paris par exemple,
mais ce ne serait qu'un exemple
parmi d'autres.
Il y a donc dans l'organisation
elle même de la ville.
Et dans cette hypothèse, maintenant
que l'on fait du Grand Paris justement
une traduction de celle de cette extension
de la capitale conçue comme en relation
avec l'extérieur et modelée pour cela,
alors on pourrait en faire la
démonstration sur Paris avec
l'organisation des transports,
des voies rapides, et cetera
Mais c'est plus large que ça.
Mais ce n'est pas seulement
la ville qui se décentre,
c'est la demeure elle même, la résidence.
Jean-Pierre Vernant, à propos de la Grèce
ancienne, avait montré que dans la maison
grecque classique,
il y avait deux divinités principales.
Il y avait le centre de la maison
qui était ombreux
et où il y avait le foyer
et qui était patronné par Héra.
La déesse Héra,
et qui était un centre féminin.
Intérieur ombre Héra.
Et puis il y avait le seuil,
le seuil qui ouvrait sur l'extérieur,
le seuil lumineux masculin
pour aller vers les affaires,
les carrefours,
les marchés, la guerre, et cetera.
Masculin.
Et c'est Hermès qui garde le seuil
et qui établit la relation
avec le monde extérieur
et à l'intérieur, le foyer, l'ombre.
Hermès
lumineux,
L'extérieur, les hommes, l'aventure.
Aujourd'hui,
qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans une demeure ?
Est bien au centre du foyer.
On trouve la télévision et l'ordinateur,
c'est à dire la relation avec l'extérieur.
Et bien évidemment, c'est Hermès
qui est là.
Car Hermès pourrait passer à juste titre
pour le dieu de
la télévision, de l'Internet, et cetera
C'est la relation, c'est la communication.
Et d'une certaine façon,
Hermès a pris la place d'Héra.
Ce que l'on
verra aussi
en ce que souvent la demeure est habitée
par des individus qui s'autonomiser
les uns par rapport aux autres.
Donc les enfants vont avoir
leur télévision, leur propre ordinateur.
Il y a une individualisation de la vie,
une tendance en tout cas
à l'individualisation de la vie
de certaines familles
qui correspond à cela.
Chacun est libre de se
projeter vers l'extérieur
et de rendre son culte à Hermès.
Mais l'individu lui même aussi
se descendre.
Je suis frappé de plus en plus
quand je monte
dans le métro de voir si c'est
une expérience toujours intéressante.
On parle du métro tout à l'heure.
Mais le métro parisien a ceci
d'assez remarquable que les gens évitent
de se regarder toujours.
C'est toujours subit comme une agression,
la possibilité d'une agression
que de porter le regard sur quelqu'un.
Donc les regards s'évitent plutôt.
En règle générale,
sauf si on parle, on se connaît.
Et cette expression est accentuée
maintenant
par le fait que la moitié du wagon
a des oreillettes
et les gens sont en train d'écouter
leur musique ou de suivre leur heure.
On ne sait pas parce qu'on n'entend pas.
Avec le développement
des téléphones portables qui sont aussi
ordinateurs, et cetera, des tas de choses.
Cette impression
de solitude,
de solitude par rapport
aux gens, de l'entourage immédiat.
Ils ne sont pas forcément seuls
puisqu'ils parlent avec d'autres
qui écoutent une musique.
Mais ailleurs.
Situation emblématique
aussi de plus en plus dans les cafés,
vous voyez
deux personnes qui sont ensemble,
qui sont assis à la même table,
mais qui ne se parlent pas,
mais qui sont en revanche
en communication avec d'autres.
Chacun a sa place, mais avec d'autres et
c'est aussi
assez drôle de marcher dans la rue
et de se rendre compte
que ce qui peuplent le plus la rue, c'est
les fantômes, c'est à dire
les fantômes de ceux
avec qui les gens qui passent
à côté de vous discutent
mais qu'on ne voit pas,
puisque bien sûr, ils sont ailleurs.
C'est ce décentrement de l'individu
lui même
qui n'est pas exactement là où on le voit
et qui peut être ailleurs,
est intéressant aussi.
Et évidemment,
il est intéressant de le mettre
en relation avec les deux autres.
Décentrement dont je parlais.
Il y en aurait un quatrième,
un quatrième en voie de constitution.
Vous savez qu'on
a parlé du tourisme planétaire
et s'il y a déjà eu une expérience,
Mais ça va se développer.
Le tourisme de luxe, bien sûr,
mais bientôt
on pourra le faire pour moins cher
et plus simplement une petite fortune
qu'on se fait
mettre sur orbite quelques instants
pour voir la Terre comme paysage.
C'est à dire, et c'est une manière
touristique de prendre conscience du fait
que nous ne sommes qu'une petite planète
comme les autres, j'allais dire,
Mais c'est
un auto décentrement
qui est assez spectaculaire si on y pense.
Et bien sûr, il y a dans ce musée
une présentation
extraordinaire de l'univers
qui nous montre bien cela.
Mais je crois qu'on
peut l'envisager aussi sous cet angle
là le fait.
Nous prenons conscience,
j'y reviendrai d'un mot,
d'appartenir à une planète
comme les autres petites
dont nous avons fait le tour,
dont nous avons fait le tour
et dont nous commençons
à nous rendre compte qu'elle est.
Elle est.
Elle est petite.
Il n'y a plus rien à découvrir,
sinon encore quelques fonds marins
et on gratte pour les trouver et on achève
l'inventaire que l'on voudrait exhaustif
des espèces de la terre.
C'est terrifiant.
Si on y pense, on est en train de faire
l'inventaire des derniers
des derniers êtres
vivants qu'on peut recenser
et il y a donc là
une idée d'achèvement
qui est intéressante.
Je reviens à l'anthropologie pour,
pour élargir mon propos, conclure
que je pense,
comme je l'avais dit au début,
que l'anthropologie
a une vocation de connaissance
et une vocation de connaissance.
Mais c'est une ligne, une parenthèse.
Les sciences humaines ou sociales
ne sont pas des sciences,
ce ne sont pas des sciences.
Au titre des sciences exactes
ou les sciences de la nature
et les sciences de la nature
ou les sciences physiques
sont des sciences qui ont un objet
qu'elles définissent
dans la connaissance
duquel elle progresse.
Les objets
des sciences sociales ou sciences humaines
sont des objets historiques,
c'est à dire
des objets qui changent avec le temps.
l'Univers naît elle même il y a un siècle
ou s'il y a des changements, c'est
pas des changements d'ordre historique.
En revanche, étudier les hommes
en société aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas comme il y a un siècle.
Donc ce sont des sciences,
ce sont des savoirs historiques
d'ordre historique qui changent.
De même que changent
les observateurs aussi dans l'histoire.
Et ça les rend à la fois plus incertaines
et il y en un sens plus complexe.
Mais que les sciences de la nature
dans ce sens
seulement que les objets bougent
historiquement.
La vocation critique de l'anthropologie,
eh bien,
c'est
de démonter
le sentiment de naturel
que nous avons toujours.
Quand un ethnologue arrive dans le village
même,
imaginons la situation ethnologique
la plus traditionnelle,
qui n'existe presque plus,
un village lointain
avec ses règles, qui est respecté.
L'ethnologue arrive déjà.
Le fait que l'ethnologue arrive
est un événement qui perturbe les choses.
Il faudra qu'il tienne compte de cette
perturbation dans son observation.
Mais ce qu'il
va faire, il va trouver des informateurs,
il va observer les choses, mais
il va essayer de se renseigner et il va
demander à des gens
de faire ce retournement du regard
qui les invite à prendre comme un objet
ce qu'ils vivent naturellement.
Lui même, l'ethnologue,
Il s'est arraché à son milieu.
Ce n'est pas absolument naturel
de quitter son environnement habituel
et d'aller pour voir comment ça marche.
C'est
à la sortie de chez soi est évidente,
elle est ressentie comme telle
et ce n'est pas pour autant
qu'on arrive chez les autres,
mais on essaie de les regarder.
C'est donc qu'il
y a un certain arrachement.
Et il arrache aussi quelques
personnes locales qu'il va prendre
comme informateurs pour leur dire
Mais qu'est ce que vous faites ?
Pourquoi ça ?
Pourquoi vous vous marier avec Rita ?
Et ces personnes vont être amenées
à se considérer comme des objets aussi,
c'est à dire à considérer que leurs usages
sont des choses qui peuvent se décrire
et pas seulement se vivre.
Autrement dit, ils vont faire l'effort
de se produire comme objet culturel,
sortir de l'espèce
des évidences naturelles
que nous avons tous lorsque nous vivons
conformément à nos habitudes.
L'anthropologie est un exercice
scabreux en ce sens qu'il
défait l'évidence du naturel.
Mais c'est pour cela
que qu'il est important aujourd'hui,
parce que tout ce que nous vivons,
y compris les changements technologiques
et les changements d'échelle
qui sont considérables,
parce que tout ce que nous vivons, c'est
un changement d'échelle, c'est évident.
Eh bien,
il faut,
il faut considérer que nous sommes dedans.
Et lorsqu'on est à l'intérieur
d'une idéologie,
eh bien, on ne la perçoit pas comme telle.
L'anthropologie peut aider à défaire
cette évidence du naturel,
ce du sens de ce que nous sentons
comme naturel aujourd'hui,
C'est cet effacement
du temps
qui n'a rien de naturel.
Nous avons du mal à penser
les deux constituants symboliques
de la vie en société
qui sont l'espace et le temps.
Le philosophe Lyotard
avait parlé de la fin des grands récits
par la fin des grands récits.
Il voulait désigner les grands récits
utopistes du XIXᵉ siècle qui, quand,
qui portaient
sur l'humanité dans son ensemble
et sur le futur,
dont le marxisme est l'un d'entre eux,
Mais il y avait
plusieurs utopies
à l'époque du XIXᵉ siècle
et ces récits,
qui portaient sur l'espèce humaine
et sur le futur, il l'est.
Il les considérait
comme les mythes de la modernité
qui s'opposaient aux mythes traditionnels,
les traditionnels étant plutôt des mythes
qui portaient sur la naissance du monde
des cosmogonies, comme on en trouve
dans toutes les sociétés,
mais cosmogonies qui généralement
sont à l'échelle d'une société.
Chaque petit groupe a sa cosmogonie,
raconte l'histoire de la naissance
du monde. La naissance du monde, c'est
l'histoire du petit groupe en question.
On peut,
au prix d'une métaphore
qui pourrait choquer certains,
considérer aussi les grandes religions
comme relevant de ces cosmogonies là.
En revanche,
les utopies du XIXᵉ siècle
portent sur l'humanité dans son ensemble
et sur le futur, pas sur l'origine.
Aujourd'hui, ces récits du futur,
à cause des épreuves du XXᵉ siècle,
nous ont paru vieillis.
Avoir eu des conséquences meurtrières.
Et on passe de l'observation de l'histoire
à la condamnation philosophique
un peu rapidement.
Peut être en sorte qu'il n'y
a rien de plus vieillot aujourd'hui
que de tenir un langage progressiste.
Ça ne fait pas moderne.
Ce qui fait moderne, c'est de considérer
que nous sommes au présent.
C'est le langage de l'ubiquité
et de l'instantanéité.
Plus d'histoire
et l'espace est accompli.
Fukuyama
lorsqu'il parle de la fin de l'histoire
et il ne parle pas de la fin
de l'histoire, au sens des événements,
bien sûr, mais il veut dire que
tout le monde est d'accord à peu près
sur l'état idéal de société, à savoir
d'une part le marché libéral,
d'autre part,
la démocratie représentative,
autrement dit l'alliance du marché libéral
et de la démocratie représentative,
représente une forme achevée sur laquelle
tout le monde est plus ou moins d'accord
et qui marque la fin de l'histoire
sous sa forme délibérative
en quelque sorte.
C'est un idéal
qui en vaut un autre, sûrement,
mais ce n'est pas vrai
parce que la fin de l'histoire,
en ce sens,
signifie
que cette relation entre démocratie
représente, acquis et marché libéral
est une relation nécessaire.
Or, l'histoire nous montre à l'envi,
et notamment dernièrement encore,
que les régimes qui ne sont pas du tout
des démocratie
représentative peuvent s'accommoder
très bien de l'économie
libérale.
Autrement dit,
le marché aujourd'hui
n'est pas nécessairement associé
à la démocratie représentative.
Autrement dit,
peut être que la
le grand fait Peut être que
Fukuyama a produit le dernier grand récit,
non plus un récit de type marxisme,
un récit de type libéral.
Et peut être que c'est un grand récit
au même titre que les autres.
Alors nous voyons bien qu'il
y a beaucoup de nostalgie aujourd'hui,
beaucoup de nostalgie et des
des images idéalisées du passé
qui s'attachent
parfois à des revendications régionales.
Mais derrière les revendications
régionales, il y a souvent la conscience
du fait qu'une région
est particulièrement développée, riche, et
qu'elle n'a pas besoin du relais de l'État
pour accéder au marché global.
Et je pense à ces régions riches
comme la Pantani en Italie ou même
la Catalogne.
La tentation est de penser
que le lien peut s'établir
directement avec le marché, qu'on n'a
pas besoin du relais politique national
alors
il y a aujourd'hui des perspectives
qui nous a peur.
Elle nous a peur
pour des raisons légitimes.
Les raisons écologiques d'abord.
Je faisais allusion à cet ultime
décentrement
qui fait que nous savons
que tout le monde sait
qu'on habite
une toute petite petite petite planète
fragile, menacée.
Les changements climatiques
nous font peur,
tout nous fait peur et
il y a cette inquiétude,
cette conscience malheureuse
qui est la conscience écologique.
Mais la conscience sociale aussi
est malheureuse,
tout au moins quand elle est lucide,
parce que
nous voyons bien,
si nous y prétend attention, que
nous ne cherchons pas vers une démocratie
généralisée à la planète entière,
nous allons vers une oligarchie.
Ce qu'il faut constater, c'est
que l'écart entre les deux.
Alors on nous dit on a raison, que
l'écart des données économiques
s'est relativement réduit entre les pays
développés et les pays émergents
ou les pays sous développés.
C'est vrai, mais ça n'empêche
que dans les trois catégories,
l'écart entre les plus riches
des riches et les plus pauvres des pauvres
ne cesse de croître.
Autrement dit, l'écart
entre la partie la plus riche du monde
où les parties les plus riches du monde.
Parce qu'il y a des riches aussi
dans des pays qui ne le sont pas
et les plus pauvres des pauvres
ne cesse de croître.
Deuxième constat c'est encore pire
dans le domaine de la connaissance
et c'est évidemment
impressionnant.
Si l'on pense que la science avance
à une allure accélérée,
ce qui est vertigineux, là
encore, c'est que nos progrès
dans la connaissance de l'infiniment
grand et de l'infiniment petit,
dans les rapports entre la vie
et la non-vie, entre l'individu
et le non individu.
Et il est évident que la science
va progresser dans des proportions telles
que nous ne sommes plus en état
de faire des projections
sur ce que nous connaîtrons dans 50 ans.
Donc, il y a cette accélération
prodigieuse et en même temps
un écart toujours grandissant
entre cette pointe
du savoir de ceux qui sont associés
à un titre ou un autre à la connaissance
et les analphabètes.
l'État d'ignorance
augmente,
y compris dans les pays développés.
Une enquête
de la Fondation nationale
pour les sciences aux États-Unis a révélé
que la moitié des Américains
ne savaient pas
que la Terre
fait le tour du soleil en un an.
Mais il y a pire.
Il y a cette
et cet éloignement absolu
de toute connaissance
scientifique, scientifique, de tout cœur,
de toute connaissance élaborée,
absolue et écart grandissant.
Autrement dit,
nous allons vers une perspective
qui, pour l'instant, est terrifiante,
surtout si, nous la rapportant
à ces grands pôles dont je disais
qu'il était l'aspect de l'Inde actuelle,
de l'urbanisation,
ça veut dire que nous allons vers
une tripartition, une oligarchie
qui se retrouvera
bien à l'oeuvre
dans les grands pôles dont je parlais,
une classe de gens
plus ou moins en rapport
avec les avancées de la science,
mais qui sont du côté de la puissance
économique
et de la connaissance
à des titres divers
mais globalement associés.
Une couche de consommateurs
parce que la consommation est
évidemment idéale et elle est nécessaire
au fonctionnement du système.
Il faut qu'on achète
les choses qui font marcher le système
mais dont on a besoin,
qui n'ont pas besoin d'être
très instruits.
Il faut qu'ils soient des consommateurs,
des biens, qu'on leur produit.
Et puis il y a la troisième couche,
qui est celle de ceux qui ne sont
ni consommateurs ni associés
à la connaissance.
C'est ça la perspective
qui est la perspective actuelle sur
Si le monde continue sur ces données là
et alors cette
Cette conclusion serait pessimiste,
évidemment, y compris sur le rôle
de l'anthropologie.
Et je crois qu'il faut,
il faut en prendre acte quand même
et poser la nécessité d'une
utopie de l'éducation.
Je suis persuadé que, en ce moment,
nous marchant sur la tête
et que
c'est un problème de finalité
parce qu'on ne pose plus les
on ne se pose plus
la question de savoir pourquoi on est là
ou pour ce que l'on pourrait faire pour
être ce que l'on peut faire sur terre.
Si on pose
comme pétition de principe que l'homme
est fait pour connaître ce qu'il est
et la terre sur laquelle il vit,
l'univers dans lequel il vit,
c'est à dire si on pose
que l'homme est fait pour reconnaître
ce qui est le sujet des grands mythes dans
les discussions
dont on a parlé pendant des siècles.
Si on admet que l'idéal de l'homme
est de connaître,
et bien il faudrait aller vers
une utopie de l'éducation.
Mais c'est une utopie
parce que nous nous en sommes loin
puisqu'elle est perspective actuelle,
montre au contraire et que
nous allons faire le contraire
et en faire l'inverse
et alors une utopie ?
Elle peut avoir ceci de bien
qu'elle peut inspirer des positions,
des prises de position et
pour l'action.
Je crois que tout ce qu'on
nous dit sur l'éducation
est insuffisant, largement.
Ce qu'il
faudrait, c'est une révolution qui donne
un rôle prépondérant
à l'éducation,
y compris
bien sûr dans les pays développés,
et un rôle d'autant plus prépondérant
qu'il puisse aider aussi les autres,
qui sont encore plus loin
dans les dents dans cet écart.
Parce que,
par exemple, la Chine
ou la Chine a
évidemment des gens brillant.
Et elle est elle ?
Elle est à la pointe de plus
en plus du progrès scientifique, mais
c'est au prix
d'un écart incommensurable entre les ceux
qui sont à la pointe du système
et ceux qui sont complètement rejetés.
Donc il y a là, il y a là un.
La durée historique est une durée lente
et la vie individuelle est courte.
Donc on ne peut pas avoir l'idéal
pour de transformer
le monde à hauteur d'individus.
Mais on peut essayer
d'essayer de dire la vérité et d'essayer
d'infléchir les choses, en tout cas
de prendre position et de le signaler.
Et je crois que tout ce qui va
dans le sens
d'une révolution éducative
est la seule nécessité
dont on puisse aujourd'hui
parler à coup sûr.
Bien entendu, ce n'est pas l'anthropologie
qui a le monopole
de la réflexion sur ce sujet.
L'anthropologie
aujourd'hui, elle est intéressante,
me semble t il, pour animer quand même
la conscience critique,
parce qu'elle porte justement sur un objet
qui est en difficulté aujourd'hui,
qui est la relation sociale,
c'est à dire l'individu lui même,
parce qu'on parle d'identité.
Mais il n'y a d'identité qu'en
relation, l'altérité,
aussi bien au niveau individuel
qu'au niveau collectif.
Et c'est ce lien
entre l'individu et ses autres
et ce lien entre le nous
et les autres qui est en cause dans le
dans ce qu'on appelle la globalisation.
Je crois donc que les observations
anthropologiques peuvent jouer leur rôle
dans la prise de conscience critique
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui.
Et pour essayer modestement
de contribuer à la réflexion.
Ce qui a bougé dans le
dans le fait, dans l'anthropologie
elle même.
Ce n'est pas tant le fait
qu'on peut aujourd'hui travailler
sur un nid, sur un immeuble d'habitation,
sur une usine
ou sur une ONG n'importe où,
pas forcément sur des sociétés
loin de l'Europe.
Mais ça, c'est normal.
Si on prend le comme objet
de l'objet intellectuel, c'est à dire
la relation dans son contexte.
Mais ce qui a bougé, c'est le fait que
du fait que le contexte devient progressivement le même pour tout le monde,
et bien
l'anthropologue lui
même fait partie du milieu qui l'observe.
Il a toujours
dû tenir compte de la place
qu'il avait, bien sûr, et parce qu'il
les pouvait, déformer les endroits
où il se trouvait par sa seule présence.
Mais aujourd'hui,
il est l'un de ceux qui l'observe.
Ça peut changer d'ailleurs
les formes de sa présentation.
Il peut y avoir.
Il peut dire jeu
en se prenant pour un exemple.
Il y a des.
Il y a des modalités d'observation
un peu différentes
qui peuvent s'exprimer différemment.
Il y a des formes anthropologique
Mais cela étant fondé sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus de possibilité d'observer
quoi que ce soit dans le monde
sans se dire qu'on en fait partie.
C'est un aspect positif.
On se sent solidaire de ce qu'on observe.
Voilà, je vous remercie.
Eh bien voilà,
il faut enregistrer tout ça,
absorber tout cela. Merci.
Merci pour cette cette belle conférence.
Je pense quand même qu'il y a peut être
des éclaircissements dont vous avez envie.
Des questions
à poser ou même des réactions.
N'hésitez pas, vous me faites signe
et on vous donne un micro tout de suite.
Voilà tout de suite Ici,
j'ai dit ça
va, ça.
Bon, évidemment,
vous insistez sur des tendances fortes
comme la globalisation par exemple,
le fait que la couleur globale
se substitue à la couleur locale.
Bon, alors, pour rester sur cet exemple.
Est ce que les tendances en question
sont absolument générales ?
Ou y a t il dans le monde des sociétés
qui soit font de la résistance,
soit même
vont carrément dans l'autre sens ?
Si on prend l'architecture par exemple,
est ce qu'il y a des lieux dans le monde
où la
société essaye justement
de ne pas faire ce qui se fait ailleurs ?
Et voilà.
Bien entendu,
j'ai parlé en tendance,
en tendance globale justement.
Et si,
si, il ?
Bien entendu, il y a une grande diversité
dans le monde et on ne peut pas parler.
D'ailleurs, on ne peut même pas parler
d'une d'une population comme les Français
ou les Anglais d'une manière
comme si c'étaient des sujets.
Et bien entendu qu'il y a des résistances.
Il y en a même que ça.
À vrai dire.
Et dans le domaine de l'architecture,
c'est
j'imagine qu'on trouverait des pays où le
je connais
des architectes
qui font le contraire de cela et
qui qui ont prôné plutôt le l'intervention
pour la réhabilitation des
des habitations, et cetera Il y a des
il y a des tas d'architectes
qui font un travail
plus, plus modeste et plus
plus plus essentiel.
Peut être.
Mais j'ai parlé du
courant
qui est d'une importance
qu'on ne peut pas ignorer.
L'extension des voies de communication,
l'extension des voies de circulation,
l'emprise de la communication,
le culte de l'image.
Ce sont des choses massives n'est ce pas ?
Alors,
bien sûr qu'il vit, qu'il
y a des tas d'esprit critique
qui prennent conscience de cela.
Mais la question est
de savoir si c'est suffisant.
Et d'un autre côté,
il y a encore une grande diversité
dans le monde, c'est vrai,
et il a des pays
qui soit par nécessité économique,
soit par vertu et résistent.
Mais je.
Et donc cela demanderait des
Il faut des études ethnologiques,
par exemple, particulières pour analyser
les pour faire des études cas.
Mais ces études de cas, même si elles
étaient des études de cas de résistance,
devraient s'insérer dans le contexte
plus vaste de ce mouvement et
en outre, je
sais que je crains
qu'il y ait une incapacité
du système global à récupérer
les manifestations de
d'originalité
ou de résistance ou d'avant garde.
À peine à peine, une voix originale
se fait entendre aussitôt.
Si elle est puissante, elle est captée
par le système et le système.
Je veux dire le marché global et c'est
donc.
C'est donc une question bien délicate.
Mais bien entendu, loin de moi l'idée de
de présenter un ensemble
unifié et achevé.
Non ?
Ce que je crois
plutôt, c'est d'ailleurs que même même
certaines de
ces violences vers lesquelles
on peut craindre que nous soyons entraînés
par c'est par la force de ces inégalités.
D'ailleurs, on le voit tous les jours,
elles influeront sur l'histoire.
Je ne sais pas ce que sera l'histoire.
Je ne suis pas en train
de décrire une fin du monde.
Mais il ne faut pas non plus que nenni.
À vrai dire,
l'histoire a toujours été violente.
Elle n'est pas le développement d'une
idée qui s'accomplit la sérénité,
et elle n'a jamais été ça.
Peut être que cela fait partie
de nos illusions.
Après les grandes guerres
et les ratés, croire que toutes choses
vont se résoudre dans la paix
et l'harmonie, ça serait la première fois
dans l'histoire.
Qu'est ce qu'il y ait d'autres questions ?
Bonsoir Mademoiselle.
Bonsoir !
Alors moi, je voulais revenir
sur la question des frontières.
Parce qu'aujourd'hui,
quand on parle, il y a beaucoup de gens
qui disent que justement,
ils rêvent d'un monde sans frontières.
Mais vous avez affirmé le contraire.
Enfin, je dis un peu contre cette idée.
Pourquoi ?
Non, je voulais discuter
du mot de frontière.
Je suis pour un monde
sans barrières, bien sûr. Mais
la frontière, la frontière, seul seuil
vous êtes pour
la frontière, est un peu est un bon mot,
une bonne,
une bonne, une bonne notion.
Parce que
c'est l'évidence
qu'il y a des frontières,
les frontières naturelles et l'histoire
de l'humanité, c'est le passage de
ces frontières progressivement.
Alors ça, ça nous a conduit à l'occupation
du globe, ça a pris un certain temps.
Mais les frontières Et
lorsqu'on dit qu'on est pour un monde
sans frontières, mais pour la diversité
et on dit
il n'y a pas eu presqu'une contradiction
parce que c'est à dire qu'il s'agit du mot
de la définition du mot frontière.
Pour moi, le mot frontière
devrait être entendu comme un passage,
la possibilité d'un passage.
Et j'en parlais en référence au seuil
auquel je faisais allusion.
Hermès rituels
les rites de passage en ethnologie.
Chacun sait qu'il
y a les passages et passages
d'un âge à un autre, le passage
d'un lieu à un autre sont toujours
des moments délicats
dans la vie des humains
et il y a toujours
une surcharge de rituels
dans les différentes cultures et les rites
varient pour faciliter ces passages
et je crois que ça, c'est une nécessité
d'ordre anthropologique.
Et lorsqu'on apprend une langue,
on franchit un seuil
et donc c'était simplement cela
que je faisais
allusion.
Le monde, alors, le monde sans frontières,
le monde sans frontières.
Malheureusement,
c'est ce sont les théoriciens du
libéralisme économique qui l'ont réalisé.
Avec des contradictions aussi.
Comme on voit bien, c'est.
Mais l'international capitaliste existe
alors que l'Internationale ouvrière
a eu du mal
et la lutte.
J'ai quelquefois écrit
Si je faisais un peu les choses,
je dis la lutte des classes. Oui, c'est
un bon concept.
Elle a eu lieu,
mais elle a été perdue et il faudrait,
après la défaite, y repenser.
Mais je sors un peu du sujet.
Le monde sans frontières, je m'amuse.
C'est une expression que je juge ambiguë,
pas d'un
pas dans l'esprit
de ceux qui le disent, avec beaucoup
de sincérité.
Mais j'aimerais mieux
un monde sans barrières.
Une autre question Oui,
vas y, vas y, tu ?
Je m'interrogeais sur le contenu
de la conférence aujourd'hui
avec ce titre L'anthropologie aujourd'hui.
Après la conférence,
je me demande si ça n'aurait pas
pu s'appeler
Anthropologie de l'eau aujourd'hui.
Et vous avez abordé en fin de conférence
le problème de la révolution
nécessaire de l'éducation
tout en disant que la prévision futur
est devenue impossible.
Comment concevez vous
cette révolution de l'éducation
sans perspective de l'avenir,
puisqu'on éduque les enfants
pour l'avenir
qu'ils auront lorsqu'ils seront adultes ?
Et comment
concevez vous cette révolution ?
Sur le premier point, vous avez raison.
C'est vrai.
Je crois que
avant de s'interroger sur l'anthropologie
aujourd'hui
qui peut se faire où l'on veut
et il faut s'interroger
sur les conditions de l'exercice
et sur la nature de l'objet.
Et c'est
cette immersion de
tout ce que l'on peut étudier aujourd'hui
dans un contexte qui est de toute manière
très contraignant,
me paraît la condition nécessaire.
Mais je suis d'accord,
on peut changer le titre.
Alors sur l'utopie de l'éducation,
j'ai tout à fait
conscience du caractère
parfaitement inachevé
et insatisfaisant de mon propos.
Et on pourrait le poursuivre
en précisant l'utopie.
Mais nous resterions
dans le registre de l'utopie.
Je suis persuadé que si
par un coup de baguette magique,
nous étions en situation de donner
une priorité absolue à l'enseignement,
c'est à dire de consacrer
des sommes folles à dire je veux dire
100 fois supérieur à ce que nous faisons,
eh bien, la conséquence à terme,
elle serait bonne
pour le reste, pour l'économie, pour
et pour la société.
Alors nous n'avons que des petits exemples
de rien du tout.
Mais il y a des continents sur lesquels
on a réussi à faire
des efforts pour l'éducation
et l'instruction des femmes dans des pays
où il n'y avait rien.
Et les conséquences économiques locales de
ce petit exemple ont été
très très encourageants et il est évident
que la science en elle même,
elle, n'a aucun intérêt à l'inégalité
et à l'inégalité économique.
C'est sur des retards dérisoires,
C'est tout ce que l'on peut faire
pour compenser cela.
Et le
simplement Bien sûr,
nous ne sommes pas dans un monde
où l'on puisse
ou l'on reconnaisse cette priorité.
Nous ne sommes pas dans un monde
assez métaphysique.
En fait, qui considérez
que le premier devoir est la connaissance,
que le reste est superflu, superfétatoire
La connaissance
n'est pas contraire au bonheur
et on pourrait disserter là dessus. Mais
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de bonheur
par l'illusion.
Mais bon, ça peut se discuter, oui.
Est ce que d'un point de vue
anthropologique,
vous avez étudié le phénomène du scolaire
là où, justement les moyens scolaires
sont à peu près convenablement donnés ?
On pourrait faire beaucoup mieux.
Mais il y a des moyens
Et la production paradoxale
du dégoût.
Non, je ne l'ai pas étudiée, bien sûr,
mais je ne vois pas en quoi
ce serait une objection.
Parce que les
le dégoût scolaire se situent quand même
dans un contexte à étudier.
Et je ne crois pas que ce soit le
qu'il faudrait étudier très précisément.
Qui sont ces dégoutés scolaires ?
Quelles sont les conditions de
leur accession à l'école D'où viennent ?
Qui leur a fait les choses classiques ?
Quand je parle de l'amélioration,
je ne demande pas une augmentation,
ce que je demande, Je ne demande rien.
Mais ce dont je rêve, ce n'est pas
une augmentation du budget de l'Éducation
nationale, c'est d'une,
c'est un renversement complet
des priorités sociales.
C'est à dire ?
J'ai bien dit que j'évoquais une utopie.
Je sais qu'on a le droit
d'avoir cette utopie.
Je dis si nous voulons avoir
une société différente,
il faut une priorité absolue
à la formation et à l'éducation.
Mais Bien entendu, là encore,
il faut entrer dans le concret.
Je ne suis pas dans l'exercice logique
à ce moment là,
je suis plutôt dans l'évocation
du contexte,
n'avait plus d'autres questions.
Pardon, Monsieur, si vous n'avez pas vu
qu'il y a Paul Virilio
qui évoque le concept d'accélération
du temps, ça vous dit quelque chose ?
Ah oui, bien sûr.
Virilio, en général
d'ailleurs, veut qu'on a une problématique
de croissance, de décroissance,
d'ignorance. Oui,
bon, c'est évident qu'on
a une accélération de l'histoire
qui est fabuleuse aujourd'hui.
Et en fait, les trois moments
qu'ont les trois,
les trois facteurs
à l'œuvre à l'heure actuelle,
je crois que c'est effectivement
cette accélération de l'histoire qui est
constante, quotidienne.
Il se passe toujours quelque chose.
Et puis on a l'histoire aux trousses
maintenant pour évoquer le passé,
on parle des bêtises des seventies,
bêtises des nineties
avec des pleurs dans la voix,
comme si c'était un passé prodigieux,
ce qui fait que ça me rajeunit pas.
Mais quand on écoute
l'évocation des nostalgies actuelles,
on a l'impression d'être un
je ne sais pas.
Un ancêtre, c'est
c'est flatteur. Mais non.
Mais cette accélération est très claire.
De même,
il y a ce rétrécissement de l'espace
que j'essayais d'évoquer
un peu rapidement,
notamment aussi à propos
du recensement de toutes les espèces.
Tout,
il y a non seulement l'espace se rétrécit,
mais l'inventaire s'achève avec à terme.
Et puis il y a cet individualisation
qui, en fait, me paraît
le prolongement de l'effort moderne.
C'est vrai que l'individu, la modernité,
définissait l'individu comme la référence
absolue, mais plutôt dans le cadre
de la définition d'un citoyen.
Et aujourd'hui,
c'est plutôt dans sa tournée
à la définition de l'individu
consommateur.
La consommation est nécessaire
à la fabrique de la machine.
Après le 11 septembre,
il a suffi qu'il y ait quelques jours
d'interruption du trafic aérien
pour que certaines compagnies aériennes
soient en faillite
parce que c'est un flux tendu.
Et donc les consommateurs
ont un pouvoir dont ils.
Qui n'a pas trouvé traduction politique
mais qui est un pouvoir révolutionnaire
considérable.
Il suffit de s'arrêter.
Consommer 20 4
h, c'est la catastrophe et alors ?
Mais on peut s'interroger effectivement
sur la nature de cette individualisation.
Et ça, c'est un vrai problème puisque
c'est aussi en regard
de cette individualisation accélérée
mais très particulière
que j'ai évoqué ce thème de l'éducation.
Parce que si vous voulez,
je crois que ce qui est en cause,
et c'est ce que montre bien Virilio,
c'est que nous avons
du mal, de plus en plus à penser
les deux constituants de la pensée
symbolique l'espace et le temps.
Et si nous avons du mal à le faire,
ça introduit un malaise dans la vie
individuelle et dans la vie sociale.
Parce que ce sont
les constituants symboliques de notre vie
et autant que identité, altérité.
Et je crois qu'il y a là des composantes
anthropologiques profondes et
qui, d'une manière ou d'une autre,
dont le malaise dont
la difficulté
à les maîtriser se traduira d'une manière
ou d'une autre historiquement.
Je le sais,
c'est un peu autour de ça.
Alors c'est vrai qu'on reproche parfois
un Virilio d'être un peu catastrophiste.
Mais moi, je suis de tempérament
plutôt optimiste par tempérament.
Mais je. Je peux bien reconnaître.
Il est troublant.
Cet état d'ignorance de vous disait
qu'il est une qui grandit,
qui grandit de plus en plus,
alors que les moyens de connaissance
se sont énormément développés.
Démocratisé aussi.
C'est un peu contradictoire.
Moi je me demandais est ce que ce n'est
pas justement cet afflux
de cette énormité de connaissance
qui nous tombe dessus ou qui nous sont
abordables ?
Pas parlé par les moyens modernes ?
Est ce que ce n'est pas ça
qui fait peut être peur ?
Trop trop.
Voilà, ça semble trop et on se dit
on n'y arrivera pas.
Et il y a une espèce de sorte
de découragement de je ne sais pas.
Peut être, je dirai
les choses, peut être un peu autrement.
Bon, c'est vrai qu'on dit que
chacun, à la bibliothèque du Congrès
dans son ordinateur et voulait en faire.
Il y a assez.
C'est ça que je voulais dire en disant
que ce pas des instruments pédagogiques.
Il y avait
pour prendre un exemple très concret,
très petit.
Quand j'ai été en Côte
d'Ivoire dans les années 60,
on avait fait une expérience
qui était intéressante en soi
pour répandre la scolarisation.
Il y avait eu une expérience de télévision
scolaire.
On avait donc mis des téléviseurs partout,
y compris dans des petits hameaux,
et cetera
Et il y avait des programmes, pas mal
faits je crois, qui devaient être diffusés
partout avec l'idée
qu'avec l'aide de l'instituteur,
ça s'est accéléré
et ça a été un grave échec. Mais
ce n'était pas un mystère.
Il aurait fallu évidemment
préparer les maîtres
à utiliser cet instrument
pour faire leur enseignement,
alors que,
comme ils n'étaient pas préparés,
ils ont eu tendance
généralement à allumer la télévision
l'heure dite, et puis allaient s'asseoir
et attendre que le programme c'est bon.
Les enfants, ils faisaient ce qu'ils
faisaient, C'est à dire ?
Ce n'était pas pédagogique.
Et je crois qu'il y a un peu
ce problème avec Internet,
indépendamment de d'autres
aspects d'Internet.
Ce n'est pas à soi seul
un instrument
qui peut enseigner la connaissance.
C'est un instrument prodigieux.
Évidemment, on peut imaginer
des choses fabuleuses à faire,
mais il faut les imaginer parce que le
et les d'abord.
Et puis il y a aussi
une grande partie de l'humanité
qui n'y
a pas accès pour oublier. Mais en fait,
abstraction faite de cela, je
crois que l'instrument lui même nécessite
une pédagogie
appropriée.
Sinon, et sinon ce serait
un instrument de consommation
que les gens astucieux pourront utiliser.
D'ailleurs, il y a sûrement les enfants.
Aujourd'hui, c'est une autre génération.
Ceux qui sont élevés avec ces instruments,
c'est une coupure.
Il est évident qu'ils ont une aisance,
que leurs aînés pourront leur envier.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire a priori
que si il n'y a pas
une pédagogie sérieuse à l'appui,
ils apprendront beaucoup de choses
sur ces deux thèmes différents.
Je crois
que oui.
On donne le micro, monsieur,
puis après on va de l'autre côté.
Oui et bonjour et excusez moi.
Tout d'abord merci pour la conférence.
J'aurais juste voulu savoir si au vu
de la société actuelle, vous pensez encore
qu'il y a une différence justifiée
entre la sociologie et l'anthropologie ?
Oh, je ne suis pas.
Je ne suis pas un exégète
des différences de disciplines.
D'abord, je crois à l'unité des savoirs.
Je réponds en plusieurs étapes.
Je crois à l'unité des savoirs
et donc je ne pense pas
qu'il
puisse y avoir de contradiction profonde
entre
entre les savoirs scientifiques,
les savoirs historiques,
et cetera Alors
je ne crois pas à une différence d'objet
radical entre sociologie et anthropologie.
Ce serait
d'autant plus stupide de le dire
que, précisément, ce n'est pas
dans le domaine des terrains empiriques
que la chose peut
maintenant se
se distinguer,
puisque il y avait un partage de fait
qui a signé
plutôt les sociétés exotiques,
entre guillemets, à l'ethnologie
et les sociétés industrielles
et à la sociologie.
Mais enfin, encore
qu'on était revenu un peu là dessus,
avec bien sûr les sociologie de l'Afrique
noire, Balandier, et cetera Les.
Non, Ce qui
est commun aujourd'hui,
c'est que vous savez,
je faisais allusion en commençant
à cette conception première qui est on va
d'abord loin et puis ensuite on s'aiguise
le regard, puis on revient chez soi.
Mais maintenant, même si on va loin pour
aiguiser le regard, on vient chez soi.
Ça a changé.
Le monde est global
et il est global aussi au départ.
Alors là où on va, autrement dit, il y a,
il y a une solidarité objective entre
les différents pays du monde aujourd'hui.
Solidarité objectif, fait de l'objet.
Alors en ce sens, oui, je dirais
sociologie anthropologique.
Je crois qu'il y a des d'ailleurs
nos ancêtres communs,
non pas les Gaulois, mais.
Durkheim et Mauss,
c'est les ancêtres de la sociologie
et de l'anthropologie.
Je dirais que
Bourdieu est aussi anthropologue
que sociologue
et par ce qui est une manière de
maintenir une petite distinction.
Je crois qu'il
y a une sociologie qualitative
qui est très proche de l'anthropologie,
alors
l'anthropologue n'est pas armée
pour traiter les grandes masses
parce que, en principe, il travaille seul,
alors que les sociologues peuvent
non pas forcément travailler en groupe,
mais s'intéressent à des données
qui sont qui peuvent être plus massives.
Cela dit, l'objet lui même, oui, bien sûr,
mais j'insiste sur le fait
que, à mon sens,
le regard anthropologique
qui peut être un regard de sociologue
par ailleurs, s'applique
davantage à la relation,
à la manière dont se négocie
les relations entre les uns et les autres.
Il me semble que c'est
une question importante parce que ça
rapprocherait un peu de la psychologie.
C'est Lévi-Strauss qui disait
que l'ethnologie est une psychologie.
Je pense qu'il faisait allusion
à des choses de ce genre le fait que
et comme nous travaillons
sur des tout petits cadres,
des petits groupes,
la manière dont se négocie
la relation dont elle est perçue,
dont elle, ce dont elle est conditionnée,
c'est plutôt ça notre objet.
Alors on peut
ensuite évidemment extrapoler.
Mais je ne crois pas qu'une différence
de nature non profonde, non.
Alors on va prendre encore
nous de questions
parce que je pense que vous commencez
peut être être fatigué.
Et puis il faut que vous alliez là bas
signer des livres
pour ceux qui le voudraient.
On va profiter de votre présence
jusqu'au bout.
Partie à cette heure demain matin
quand même.
Allez y.
Merci beaucoup pour cette conférence.
Dans le cadre du contexte planétaire,
j'ai une question
qui relève peut être
pas de votre conférence je ne sais pas.
Je me pose la question sur l'anglais
international, l'anglais des aéroports.
Cette langue, est ce que c'est un non lieu
de communication.
Et deux questions subsidiaires est ce que
ça relève du contexte ou de la relation ?
Cette langue
presque artificielle ?
A vous de dire.
Et est ce que vous entrevoyez
la langue ou le langage de l'avenir
de la ville, de l'avenir dans l'avenir ?
Oui, c'est des questions immenses
sur l'anglais. Oui.
Les Anglais sont les premiers
à se désespérer du succès de leur langue,
sauf ceux qui sont très paresseux,
qui ne veulent pas
prendre de langue étrangère,
mais parce que la langue se dégrade.
On cite toujours l'exemple de ceux
de ce lord anglais dont le rapport a
je ne sais quelle institution de l'Unesco
a été repoussé pour l'engager illisible.
Oui, c'est une langue
un peu cet anglais là, c'est vrai.
En ce sens, c'est vrai.
Et c'est vrai aussi que c'est le
laisser la
langue parlée dans un certain nombre
de ces endroits que j'ai appelé non lieu.
Oui, c'est vrai aussi,
mais ça va plus loin que ça.
Et justement, c'est
la question des langues est
une question très importante
parce que si nous, il ne faut pas
en règle générale,
un interlocuteur, s'il
y a deux interlocuteurs,
que l'un parle dans sa langue
et l'autre non,
le premier est avantagé.
Sauf de très rares
exceptions, de gens parfaitement
bilingue ou trilingues.
Mais on est quand même
même dans une langue qu'on parle
un peu, on est moins à l'aise.
Donc il faut aurait.
On a peut être tendance
à penser que aujourd'hui, il y a un
un avantage
aux Américains, aux Anglais, parce qu'ils
ils ont la maîtrise du langage.
Mais j'ai l'impression que c'est une chose
qui est en train de bouger.
D'une part,
d'une part, l'espagnol
est une langue parlée dans le monde, aussi
il y a d'autres langues
qui sont très parlées et
d'autre part,
il va y avoir les systèmes de traduction
font de grands progrès
et les traductions automatiques qui seront
qui sont déjà bien améliorées
mais qui font des progrès encore
ne nécessiteront pas nécessairement
l'emploi de l'anglais comme langue.
Donc je crois que oui, il y a des cépages.
On peut poser le problème
de l'avenir des langues.
Je suis un farouche partisan de la défense
langues, de la pluralité des langues
et parce que précisément,
ce sont des frontières
et des frontières qu'il faut passer.
Il faut passer les frontières
qui ne sont pas des barrières.
On est bien d'accord, des frontières
Bien sûr, ce n'est pas des barrières, Il
ne faut pas que ça soit des barrières et
d'ailleurs, je trouve que
nous, on est parfois un peu timides
dans le programme de langues.
On parle de
se séparer,
on fait l'Europe et on apprend l'anglais.
Et ici, mais eux, ils n'ont pas l'euro.
Il faudrait, il faudrait.
Il y a des langues
qu'on pourrait facilement juger,
pas forcément classe élémentaire, mais
je trouve qu'il devrait y avoir un
pas dans l'analyse
des programmes scolaires parce que
je peux peut être conclure.
Il y avait encore une question,
alors ce sera oui, ce sera la dernière.
Est ce que les systèmes éducatifs
aussi bien français
que ne se sont pas fourvoyés
dans des théories loufoques ?
Je pense notamment à une conférence
qui s'est déroulée ici même
il y a quelques années,
où l'invité était Stanislas Dehaene.
Et il va revenir bientôt.
Et il nous disait que
la méthode globale
était une erreur absolue.
Et en, il nous disait Non seulement
la méthode globale est une erreur absolue,
mais là la méthode globale
où 1/10 de global
est également une erreur absolue
parce que le cerveau
n'est pas apte à décrypter cette méthode.
Donc est ce qu'il n'est
pas temps de revenir à des méthodes
plus performantes par ailleurs ?
Donc,
l'exercice de la citoyenneté
n'est possible
que, comme l'a dit
Amartya Sen, si l'individu est capable
d'exercer ce pouvoir de citoyen,
donc le mot qui l'emploie,
c'est le mot capabilité.
Et pour qu'un individu soit capable
d'exercer cette citoyenneté,
il faut qu'on lui apprenne
donc, notamment en lui
faisant acquérir des notions de droit
dès le tout jeune âge.
J'écoutais une émission
la radio l'autre jour.
Il y avait un professeur de droit
qui disait Le droit devra être enseigné
aux enfants dès l'âge de six ans,
aux cinq six ans, donc adaptés à leur âge.
Bien sûr. Mais
s'il n'y a pas cet apprentissage là,
il ne peut pas y avoir d'exercice réel
de la citoyenneté.
Je crois que vous avez raison
sur les devoirs.
Je ne suis pas un spécialiste des méthodes
de lecture,
mais je suis persuadé que je suis persuadé
intimement comme cela,
que la méthode globale
est une méthode à rejeter.
D'abord parce que je ne vois pas non plus
pourquoi, à mon avis,
il n'y a pas, il n'y a pas de.
Il n'y a pas de contradiction
entre le fait d'apprendre
à lire ou à écrire
et celui de faire du calcul et des maths.
Il n'y a pas de sortes d'intelligence,
peut être plusieurs formes d'intelligence,
mais je ne crois pas qu'il puisse y avoir
contradiction absolue.
Moi, je ne sais pas. J'ai l'impression
que la méthode traditionnelle
marchait bien quand j'étais jeune.
On apprenait facilement à lire.
Je sais qu'à mon âge,
ça fait bébête de dire ça parce que
j'ai l'air d'opposer un
âge paradisiaque à une calamité actuelle.
Alors je ne veux pas assisté là dessus.
Mais je crois, oui.
De façon générale, il faut un petit peu,
peut être se méfier des méthodes.
Alors je parlais de pédagogie
tout à l'heure.
Mais il faut se méfier aussi
de la pédagogie.
Ça c'est sûr.
Pour le droit, oui, bien sûr.
Moi, je crois qu'on devrait apprendre
à être citoyen très jeune, très jeune
et à partir de vérités élémentaires,
du respect, l'autre, et cetera
Oui, oui, mais c'est à dire ?
J'ai toujours dans la tête,
j'ai deux choses
dans la tête qui sont
des des principes comme ça.
C'est d'une part les lumières
et le XVIIIᵉ siècle.
Et puis
d'autre part le,
l'éducation,
l'information, le.
Et bien voilà, on va en rester là.
Je voulais juste vous dire à propos de M.
Hahn, que je l'ai invité parce qu'il
vient de sortir un nouveau livre, fait
un livre qui est ré réédité, amélioré,
et cetera sur la bosse des maths.
Et on l'a invité pour, à partir du mois
de mars, Stanislas Dehaene.
Voilà. Merci, vraiment grand, grand merci.
Marc, j'ai.
Voilà
Marc Augé, le
grand jeune voyageur qui reprend la route
dès demain et qui nous a fait vraiment
un grand honneur en venant ici
dans nos mardis de l'Espace des sciences.
On va prendre l'ascenseur.
On vous retrouve là haut, derrière
la table des livres, si vous voulez dire.
Un petit mot personnel, monsieur.
Bonne soirée à vous.
Merci de votre attention
et à bientôt, j'espère.